going out to Iowa Holly how can I help
you today good good thank you for taking
my call oh thank you for calling in so
so I am I'm calling today I am currently
a sophomore at a community college in
Iowa to consummate this spring debt-free
paid off but I have decided to go on in
a bachelor's degree and I currently have
about twelve thousand dollars in savings
I applied for the FAFSA and activate
applying for scholarships but I just
don't think that's going to be enough
for me to pay for two more years glowing
and I was just wondering what advice you
have making man you know I love the fact
you even call in having this
conversation with me you know this is
something I'm really really passionate
about wish I could stand up and had this
conversation because I love it so much
so let's get a bit more information here
how are you right now
Holly I'm 20/20 okay are you living at
home with your parents right now you
have your own place my own place okay
all right now right and do you have any
student loans from your community
college right now I do not know okay
cool so right now we're in a good place
okay we're debt-free it sounds like you
have any credit cards or anything I
might do but I thought like $10 on it a
month okay how much credit card debt do
you have ah none not okay okay and you
say you have a credit card you put $10
on it a month that I hear you correctly
yeah yeah okay okay okay so we need it
we need to cut that credit card up
alright I know that's not why you call
it in but I want to make sure that we're
staying away from all debt because I
want you to graduate ahead of the game
not behind the game so let's go ahead
and get this credit card cut up so what
school are you looking at going to how
much is it is it a year I'm so I'm
looking at 17,000 mm-hmm okay with
housing is it possible you can stay home
no from home okay four hours from home
all right and how much is the tuition
alone right at about eleven thousand
okay so
about 11,000 and that's what I was
thinking because normally all in states
not all of them but the majority of I'm
about in between six to eleven thousand
and then housing you're saying is about
six thousand dollars a extra a year okay
yeah I'm gonna do some math here because
way I'm thinking are you working right
now okay well how much are you making
them up little over two hundred it's not
much just when I have all kinds of
college okay off time from college
alright so what it sounds like here
Holly what I'm gonna recommend you do is
eleven thousand dollars a month it's not
too bad that's gonna be about nine
hundred dollars a month what you need to
come up with now the housing situation
I'm gonna recommend since you're four
hours away is try to figure out how you
can get an apartment or get into a
situation to where you can actually
split this income if you cannot do that
then what we got to look at is we have
seventeen thousand dollars how can we
cashflow do I need to go into the job
immediately not into the job into the
college education my four-year degree
right now immediately is the way I can
actually work and save up some money is
there a way that I could possibly secure
some more grants and scholarships
I wouldn't think I would actually
suggest that you go up to the financial
aid office and see if you can negotiate
you know cuz this is this is serious
you're going into it right let's make
sure you graduate from it right now
right